et la finale qu'on vient de vivre à
l'instant sur de gibraltar juste a juste
à l'instant et donc et donc on arrive
ici et c'est le premier jeudi du mois du
couperet est fini du moins qui tombe le
premier jour du mois du coup la en vf
ont fait coup double ont fait coup
double ont fait coup double et donc qui
dit premier jour du jour un premier
jeudi du mois pardon
dix tournois habite rires j'ai envie de
dire donc toi un briefing thomas
bitstream et donc tour à bitstream
tourabi stream à 20h30 alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait comme toi ce soir les mecs
c'est un peu la question qu'on est en
droit de se poser
je vais vérifier que le stream est bien
commencé comme d'habitude voilà on a
bien commencé passé j'avais des gens qui
sont arrivés ou quoi mais je sais qu'on
soit un tournoi normal on fait on fait
on fait comment que fait-on qu'est ce
qu'on fait on se fait un petit 3 + 2
comme on a eu l'habitude de faire de
façon bad en tournoi on va faire club
tournament on va faire beast rim fait
briller je vais mettre leur on va mettre
20h35 la cadence ou le m 3 plus deux
comme ça à faire comme les départage de
maxime
et on va faire on va faire on va faire
on va faire conviendront va faire cinq
ronds ont fait combien on fait quoi que
fait-on ouais ça de baisse et 3 + 0 mais
bon on va peut-être plutôt faire les
trois plus de ses plus c'est plus et
plus et plus fun quoi c'est plus drôle
permet aux gens de d'un petit peu joueur
qui à goiania lié à l'autre événement
aussi à le machin soeur emily blunt
arena là je crois qu'il est cité le
mercredi ils ont passé le jeudi je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas mais bon toute
façon vous stade tournoi du jeudi ça
fait des années qu'on fait notoire du
jeudi en fin d année
ça fait maintenant presque un an je
pense qu'on fait notre tournoi du jeudi
tous les jeudis soirs alors on fait 3
plus est ce qu'on échec standard on est
on est quoi après derrière que met-on
derrière après est ce qu'on fait des
échecs normaux et ce qu'on fait du 960
ou est-ce qu'on fait une variante genre
king of the hill crazy house
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
je suis allé prendre l'eau chat duchess
points comme aussi d'avoir tout lé chat
tout avoir bien ouvert déjà de check
point comme moi pas la voir s'ils sont
encore sûr c'est encore sur le festival
ils sont encore sur gibraltar tue pas
sûr que je suis pas sûr qu'on soit je
suis pas forcément sûr qu'on soit à
qu'on soit sur czech comme tv donc on va
rester entre nous parce que je vois
qu'il ya plein de stream différent et je
les sens plus mettre d'autres stream que
le nôtre son coût est complètement
bloquée donc il va avoir le truc de
gibraltar qui va rester il analyse la
partie avec les bonnes on va rester
entre nous sur twitter
mais du coup on sera peut-être pas super
nombreux peut-être qu'on sera pas super
nombreux bons matches mais 3 plus de
l'écouté je vais le créer 20h35
on va se créer sa tranquille où j'ai
envie de vous dire donc le tournoi est
lancé un petit peu un petit peu
reprendre mes esprits au monde ce que
les sectes les départage je n'ai pas vu
grand chose dans certaines parties dans
d'autres c'était plutôt pas mal commenté
ça dépend des jeux voir un peu ce qu'on
écrit j'ai déjà les notifications les
trucs de partout donc j'en profite et
1,32 petites minutes j'ai créé le j'ai
lancé le touran vous pouvez déjà vous
inscrire au tournoi
je vois qu'il ya oui sncf qui m'écrit
j'ai envie de te dire c'est un peu le
mail que tu attendais le mail oui sncf
qu'est-ce qui m'écrivent pense déjà aux
vacances d'été où il assène cfa sncf qui
pensent déjà aux vacances hum hum hum
vacances de vacances à tout-va quoi eux
ils font des vacances à tout va soit
vacances d'été c'est un peu pour
chambrer 1 ça fait pas de mal ça fait
pas de mal donc le tour aventura février
est ce que est ce que les gens ont même
oublié qu'ils avaient ce tournoi parce
que j'aimerais qu'une personne en crise
at the bass seul inscrit va-t-on réussir
même affaire ce tournoi afin que j'écris
sur le disque hors d'eux peut-être sais
pas s'il ya des gens du discorde qui
sont là j'allais leur écrire
ben je vais arriver avec le smartphone
tient certes plus facile que d'aller
cliquer de partout je vais prendre le
smartphone et je vais leur écrire
n'oubliez pas le tour à double à
n'oubliez pas le tournoi de 2 février un
les mecs
ouais parce que j'ai envie de te dire
ils sont en train de l'oublier
et si mon ami es qu'est ce que le
discorde avait même mis le lien du live
sur sur maxime où il a des faits il
avait fait incroyable refusant à parler
de ce tournoi ont déjà trois joueurs ça
ça va ça arrive petit à petit ça arrive
petit à petit
ça arrive petit à petit on va peut-être
faire un petit post facebook aussi pour
dire que pour dire que maxime en vous
laissant vous inscrire tranquillement et
sans les voir arriver les gens se
connecter pour parler de cet horrible
victoire d'arreau nian méritée après il
faut reconnaître il a bien joué
qu'est ce que vous voulez on peut rien y
faire
on ne peut rien y faire
c'est la deuxième fois quand même fin ça
commence à faire beaucoup l'aronia 9
ça commence ay commence à devenir
pénible en fait moi je l'aimé bien de
base de ba j'aimais bien les vols mais
mais maintenant je commence à commença
plus être copains là on commence a pu
être copain avec les bonnes aronian ça
commence à faire un peu trop de victoire
pour pour lui sur maxime ça commence à
en faire un peu beaucoup
le même tee shirt trop une photo il est
même t-shirt est vrai ça commence à en
faire un peu beaucoup la ja merci à toi
comment je fais alors pourtant inscrit
retour impôts directs eu 100 inscrits au
club bitstream zhiwei faut déjà que tu
t'inscris vos clubs bitstream or le club
lead stream faut vraiment que je fasse
un tuto en c4 le club vitrine jettent
récupérer l'adresse et que tu après
taille d'un jeu en direct
et comme ça tu pourras t'inscrire
tournant alors attends l'adresse suis en
train de la récupérer elle est là et que
tu te balades après donc déjà que tu
rejoigne le club c'est complètement
gratuit 1 et ensuite que tu ailles que
die dans che ce point comme slash live
et que tu ailles dont tournoi à une fois
qu'il sera inscrit au club
tu pourras trouver le tournoi déjà cinq
inscrits je vais juste mettre donc un
petit un petit facebook pour pour tenir
les gens au courant on va écrire leeuwen
aronian ray on va devoir l'écrire
malheureusement
mettre un petit bec qui pleure on va
mettre un
nami quelqu'un qui pleurait un petit
smiley qui pleure tu as réussi à
rejoindre ma bien joué bien joué bien
joué dit ouais je te vois tu es 348 donc
tu vas un peu souffrir je te cache pas
mais mais ça va permettre d'apprendre
donc c'est ton premier tournoi c'est la
première fois que tu suis no string
telle était la tête ou têtes et des thés
complètement nouveaux ou pas en fait
c'est un peu la question qu'on se pose
alors effet nommé et souvent pour
agression c'est pourquoi la vidéo date
sol sinon bah quand absolue la mettra en
ligne je pense qu'il va la mettre dans
quelques dents peut-être dans une ou
deux semaines je pense assez bientôt
donc ça devrait ça devrait arriver à
zioui qui a débuté à trois semaines et
et paraît pas évident a dit ouais mais
ne t'inquiète pas ça va venir petit à
petit à force d'entraînement tu va
progresser et puis après après tu nous
tous nous battre à tous quoi nous
verrons tout ce dont nous nous
déconnecteront qua non nous ne voulons
pas jouer contre si vous aimez beaucoup
trop fort pour nous il est magnifique
n'aura pas le temps mais il commencera
le 3 août et déjà neuf donc ça va on
sait que ça commence à venir petit à
petit à la discorde qui va arriver de la
croix 0,3 je peux d'ailleurs aussi nous
suivre sur youtube andy white utah
bitstream
si tu trouveras la chaîne une chaîne en
anglais une chaîne en france est foutue
la chaîne en france est automatiquement
du stream échec et tu peux aussi nous
suivre là bas tu peux tu peux ne sut de
partout partout tout le temps
tabbone émettent des like enfin faire
comme les autres quoi j'ai envie de te
dire
donc tu me suis déjà tu ne me suis déjà
et ben bravo et bravo
déjà trois semaines tu es déjà dans tes
déjà dans le tempo quoi directs d'entrée
ok merci sinon tu as une bonne référence
d'échiquier le staunton 5 et bien ouej
l'estonie sont assez beau après chez moi
j'ai qu'un échiquier par un petit
échiquier mais sinon les stones sont
beaux et peut-être à l'avenir y aura
aussi un échiquier bitstream qui sortira
mais c'est pour enfin aussi quelques
têtes voire quelques mois avoir voir
année c'est pas si simple à mettre en
place mais mes weston c'est une bonne
c'est une bonne référence
salut madhav chasse il ya beaucoup de
nouvelles personnes là dans le chat des
gens que je n'ai jamais vu ma date chez
elle mais j'ai un peu plus quoi oui je
fais tout mon possible pour progresser
en apprendre plus à commencer par
regarder des vidéos à nos vidéos sont
être un peu hard un devis ne sont
peut-être un peu hard
regardez les commentaires aussi par
maggio produit est-il hier un match trop
de celle ci qui était vraiment haletant
hier est ce qu'on peut avoir des infos
sur les matchs de prod classique de
dimanche soir dimanche en fête en fête
dimanche ça va être un match contre
toutes les équipes de partout en fait on
va jouer contre contre contre huit
équipes de la ligue je sais même plus de
qualité en train d'essayer de regarder
sur le site pour avoir les infos en gros
on va jouer quand huit équipes
différentes et nous on a une équipe très
très amoindri comme je le disais tout à
l'heure dans le live moi je vais jouer
mais je sais pas si je vais être d'une
grande aide parce que j'ai une petite en
overdose d'échec en fait
et du coup le week-end j'essaye
normalement de me2 pas trop joué là ça
fait deux week-ends d'affilée que je
jouais en équipe donc jouer avec mon
équipe en bas en temps réel là pour la
peine pas sûr pas sur internet mais mais
mais en dur vous avez pu voir une de mes
parties sur la chaîne d'ailleurs est
donc là dimanche même même moi qui suis
pas et ne serai pas en forcément grande
forme je vais devoir jouer parce qu'il
nous manque mathieu cornette maxime
lagarde fab libye valentina qui peut pas
jouer non plus enfin en gros en gros on
n'aura qu'un grand maître ce sera robert
robert qui joue bien mais qui est quand
même un peu en dessous de 2 maxime
lagarde ou mathieu cornède pas qu'ils
jouent vraiment intrinsèquement moins
bien mais juste il est plus joueur
professionnel forcément moins de
pratique au deuxième on aura une recrue
à route
donc il joue bien mais qui est 24,50
24,60 quelque chose comme ça donc c'est
un bon jeune il a une vingtaine d'années
mais là encore par rapport aux 1,2 qu'on
a d'habitude quand on est la garde ce
sera quand même bien moins fort aux
trois en or à pierrot mon pierrot qui
joue très bien mais qui d'habitude est
notre quatrième échiquier donc si on
compare et +24 on a démonté ou goût nina
quand on est en équipe max et jours et
mois aux quatre et je suis quand même un
poil moins fort que démentent et ou
pierrot qu'on peut parfois avoir aux
quatre donc finalement on sera un peu
moins fort que d'habitude surtout les
échiquiers des fois déjà qu'on a un peu
juste quand à notre équipe max et
surtout qu'on est prêts on est bien
moins fort à chaque fois
donc on est quatre fois moins fort que
d'habitude mais on essaiera de se battre
ou sera de balancer des grappes de
s'amuser surtout alors il ya mathieu
knie qui est content de suivre un live
pour la première fois c'est cool pouces
bleus pour toi alfredo ruiz marié j'ai
commencé à jouer sérieusement il ya un
mois le jour 3 heures par jour je suis
passé de 1000 à 1400 et loi et c'est une
belle progression
j'imagine que tu es jeune qui a gagné
contre londres et ben on a gagné huit et
demi cet ennemi et imada qui est malade
sur dix corps mais qui a changé de
pseudo et donc voyons dimanche ce sera
dur le vraiment le match important le
match on remet encore une belle équipe
ce sera mercredi prochain à 20h35 on
jouera contre la l'autre équipe de
londres et donc il faudra gagner alors
le match de dimanche prochain à bath et
ça compte pareil que les autres matches
en fait mais bon il ya un système de
classement poussent un peu compliqué en
fait pourtant courte pour vous dire la
vérité on n'est vraiment pas très
motivée par le match de dimanche
c'est beaucoup trop long ça dure quatre
heures comme je vous dise on n'est pas
forcément super motivé de passer quatre
heures sur notre dimanche surtout pour
les gens qui travaillent dans les échecs
en fait donc on n'est pas mes gars
motivés pour ce match après l'appétit
vient en mangeant on commencera à jouer
de toute façon on fera notre de notre
mieux je sais que même moi je n'ai pas
très envie de jouer dimanche dernier 2
samedi dernier s'est joué samedi
c'est génial je n'ai pas très envie de
jouer avec mon équipe de monaco il y
avait un gros déplacement on a fait 200
bornes pour aller pour aller jouer et je
n'avais pas très envie je t'ai pas mes
gars motivés avant mais bon une fois que
je me suis assise et que mon adversaire
m'a forcé à appuyer sur sur sur la
pendule puisque j'avais les noirs on
magnifie les noirs acquis sur la pendule
mon adversaire était l' arbitre du match
dont ils ont envie de tenir
plus trop le choix et une fois une fois
qu'il a appuyé sur la pendule et où sa
main même s'il avait envie de jouer de
base ou quoi pas très envie une fois
qu'on y est on y est alors après on joue
peut-être un peu moins bien mais ok le
truc c'est qu'on va pas faire exprès de
perdre de toute façon on sera là bon je
balancerai des grottes fait envie de me
marrer tous mais enfin on va on va on va
tenter enfin on va essayer de faire du
mieux qu'on peut et qui va commenter
c'est moi qui vais commenter mes propres
partis en fait c'est moi qui
commenterait mais propre parti
donc comme ça comme ça on pourra quand
même suivre le match comme visée on joue
pas pour grand-chose la ville et
l'objectif c'est de se marrer donc on
veut vraiment que tous les matchs
pro-chasse tic soit suivi qui soit sur
la chaîne et tout ça est donc donc je
commenteront en direct ce sera sympa on
va s'amuser qua non mais vraiment tout
joueur bon allez allez faux faux faux
faux faux s'inscrire un peu on peut
monter plus haut 1 12 joueurs c'est
quand même un peu limité on a eu des
fois on était trente ans que se
passe-t-il dans le tuto pour le tournoi
faut vraiment que tu ailles sur le club
literie donc tu vas tish sur le club
lead stream tu te tu t'inscris sur le
club liste rim et puis après tu vas dans
la partie live de tchatche.com comme si
tu allais jouer en direct et tu
trouveras le tournoi subi qu'il dit
c'est chaud de joconde et j'aime encore
montant non bah oui bon forme j'ai quand
même l'habitude de le faire non sur ces
détails tels tu sais où j'ai très bien
joué en commentant après c'est du 10 + 2
on verra mais on est on est là pour
faire de l'interdît ning un cubi
on est là pour faire du notaire téning
pour s'amuser pour pour amuser les gens
pour amuser la galerie c'est aussi ça
qui rend les échecs
ceci ça qui rend les échecs plus
populaire c'est qu'il ya des gens comme
comme nous mais comme beaucoup d'autres
les chefs bras john bartholomew fin il
ya beaucoup de monde qui fait des lives
des parties en direct et tout ça ça emon
williams moment pour en citer des
dizaines mais c'est aussi grâce à ça que
les échecs reprennent un peu de
popularité donc j'ai envie de dire
parfois faut passer un petit peu aussi
c'est ça aussi une certaine importance
on va dire ça aussi une certaine
importance donc nous ça nous fait
plaisir d'avoir une équipe qui est très
suivie pour pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée d'après ce que je sais on est
l'une des deux sur je ne sais pas si on
est une des deux trois équipes les plus
suivis de pro-chasse league alors qu'on
n'est pas une équipe anglophone ou
forcément on a potentiellement moins de
gens qui peuvent qui peuvent nous suivre
de base puisqu'on antenne morocco found
to know ce crime soient en français et
on a une équipe avec quasiment que des
joueurs français pourtant est une des
équipes de produits éthiques des plus
suivies donc à nous ça nous fait kiffer
en fait ça fait kiffer les joueurs de
devoir qui a autant d'engouement et qui
équipe est vraiment suivi et qu'on a
beaucoup de entre guillemets supporters
mais oui on peut on peut dire supporters
comme comme une équipe de foot donc ça
fait vraiment plaisir aux joueurs ça et
ça mais moi ça me fait kiffer afin de le
dire voilà on a monté notre équipe de
pro che stick tout ça et on peut faire
suivre une compétition une compétition
échiquéenne sur plusieurs mois avec avec
un avec un bel engouement c'est quand
même sympa c'est quand même sympa il ya
peu d'autres par les échecs ça
n'existait pas vraiment avant si vous
suivez c'est pas mal quand on parle de
confession française va pas forcément se
comparer avec les étrangers on connaît
pas trop si vous regardez le top 12
le top-12 ya pas grand monde qui suit en
fait tout le monde s'en fout en gros
donc là c'est sympa d'avoir un truc
d'échec les gens peuvent peuvent
supporter une équipe voir des match
vibrer je trouve ça fait une belle
publicité pour le jeu d'échecs perso et
donc c'est aussi ce qui nous tient à
coeur dans cette compétition c'est un
nos objectifs aussi au delà de bien de
bien faire est bon de se maintenir ou
d'aller en playoffs mais c'est aussi ça
donc voilà ça ça ça cette importance
pour nous alors le tour est ouvert à
tout le monde il faut simplement
participer au club d'échecs bitstream
je remets le lien qui participent au
club et tu vas pouvoir et tu vas pouvoir
y participer en toute simplicité
en toute simplicité
donc
alors tu trouves pas donc faut aller en
premier faux tu t'inscris faut que tu
participes au club on s'est écrit
participer et dans un deuxième temps
faut que tu colles faut que tu colles
chez.com live pour pour trouver le
tournoi dans la rubrique tournois après
un pour la peine soit pas être méga
compliqué non plus les mecs si vous
suivez la marche à suivre ça devrait le
faire
il ya déjà du beau jeu à celle de seb
qui est de nouveau favoris du tournoi
il ya du beau joueur dans ce tournoi on
est moins nombreux cette semaine suis
pas pourquoi les gens entrent en jeu les
dix ans il n'y a qu'en live est ou non
mais même sur le discorde sa partage pas
elle joue sous un peu mou là ce soir
il ya du niveau dans les inscrits je
m'excuse d'avancé dans tout ce qui se
passe à tous on a tous commencé quelque
part on a tous commencé en apprenant les
règles mathieu t'inquiète pas
au contraire c'est une bonne expérience
de jouer contre des joueurs plus forts
je vais mettre le lien sur sur le
discorde
twitch pointe effet de chasse comme
échec
je la connais par coeur dans l'adresse à
force tiré vers le bas le jazz comme
échec
ça va peut-être avoir quelques personnes
supplémentaires qui vont nous rejoindre
et plus dont démarre dans quatorze
minutes
the nation face il y obtient well kevin
ouais ça va merci tu parles tu parle
français ou pas hendrik good ses canards
qui apparemment a trouvé le tournoi
niang il est deuxième et loïc qui se
considère pas comme ça ferraille à ya un
gros il ya un gap là il ya un gap entre
le premier et le deuxième
il ya un vrai gap c'est surtout le
numéro un qui fait peur c'est surtout
celle de sel mathieu qui voit il
faudrait que tu mettes l'url du groupe
chasse - comme dans la chaîne youtube
j'ai vraiment du mal à trouver
en fait c'est là un non c'est pas
celui-là ma main se venger le mauvais
groupe
tu parles de cale url du club du club du
club en fait tu parles du club et de
cette url accueilli en train de m je
suis pas quand tu la vois exactement il
ya toujours un petit délai mais jamais
dans le chat un généralement mathieu
mais elle n'est pas forcément vraiment
utile un pur pour les gens cette url
parce que elle sert uniquement à jouer
les tournois blitz stream du jeudi donc
c'est les gens qui viennent sur twitch
de toute façon mais c'est peut-être dû
mettre un message pour rappeler le tour
noire absents que les gens ont oublié le
tournoi on commence au mois de février
direct le 1er février boom
1er février un jeudi les gens
complètement oublié que c'est le premier
jeudi du mois ce calcul on est vraiment
plus en et 14 c paraissait et c'est
léger c'est léger ouais en fait surtout
ils font fait pas beaucoup de live
d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien faire plus de
live sur twitter mais j'ai l'impression
que ça fait trop de chaînes différentes
après et que et que du coup on s'en sort
pas trop hein ça ça fait trop
d'adressent qui a réussi à s'inscrire
il ya aussi de chasse 30,54 qui
s'inscrit donc là on prend du level high
class 30 54
on prend clairement du level puisqu'il
passe classé numéro 1 2302 le duc de
normandie qui est là aussi des ressauts
chase a cédé habitués qui chantonne
abdellah il s'est hissé inscrit ri
vilches tout ça on les voit souvent
allez on peut peut-être une vingtaine
qu'est ce que je conseille pour
apprendre à calculer à faire des
exercices tactiques en fait via un via
des livres ou via des entraîneurs
tactique mais en les faisant rentrer un
tract sur un thème dans les besoins de
manière très honnête c'est à dire ne pas
jouer le coup donc sur internet s'est
pas bougé la pièce une fois que bon tu
as tu penses à retrouver pas de suite
bouger et ça veut dire si le fait sur un
livre pas à les regarder la réponse dès
que tu penses avoir le premier bon coup
c'est faire les exercices vraiment de
manière très honnête en calculant un
maximum en essayant d y en eut en
essayant d'avoir vu toutes les lignes
possibles et imaginables pour être sûr
que ça marche en fait et comme ça tu
progressera
donc ça c'est ça mon avis la manière de
procéder la manière de faire à mon
humble avis pendant un commentaire
on démarre dans onze minutes
ne vous inquiétez pas un autre façon si
vous perdez la première partie vous
serez à parier qu'on des gens qui ont
péri a perdu la première partie donc
très rapidement vous allez jouer contre
des gens de vote de votre niveau donc il
faut pas ce faux pas s'inquiéter ça va
aller tout seul vous n'allez pas
souffrir peut-être un peu souffrir mais
pas trop qui tue qui et 1400 monts
kunlun ans et toi ça va 1400 tu es dans
tes dents et édenté dans le ventre mou
du classement si je puis dire
mathieu qui est très excité salut je
suis le live en léger différé ça a coupé
d'un coup quelqu'un le résultat de
gibraltar battu pourra regarder en
replay en fait un peu te le cacher en
fait ça le fait les live au bout d'un
moment ils peuvent devraient ils peuvent
être décalés il m'indique pourra faire
que les deux premières rondes bah ouais
ok c'est la vie hein tu fais ce que tu
peux on est 21e laisse arrivent petit à
petit j'ai vu ton classement elo que
faut-il pour passer le cap de 1700 et à
arriver à 2700 il faut beaucoup de
travail beaucoup de talent
les deux du travail et du talent
un mélange des deux
donc ouais tu verras en replay d'aidé
que dès que le traitement de la vidéo
sur youtube sera fait je mettrai la
vidéo en replay la finale c'est quand
même une belle finale
ça mérite d'être en replay qui pas si
vous préférez dû coûter une petite
question là pendant qu'on est tranquille
il reste sept huit minutes souvent
demandé des vidéos de d'analyser tout ça
mais est ce que ça vous plaît d'avoir
parfois des semaines où on n'a que des
lives là par exemple cette semaine il va
quasiment que des vidéos de live parce
que j'en avais fait on avait mis un truc
en ligne lundi
je me rappelle plus ce que c'était il y
en a et mima partie d'heures en ligne
lundi donc une analyse de partie
la douce est une des premières semaines
où s'affairent live de produits s league
live de la finale de gibraltar live
fraude chez ce league
on va de nouveau avoir live the title
tuesday suis pas si vous aimez bien fait
un beau coup de la rive comme ça aussi
ça fait trop de la rive que françois
aussi une question c'est une question si
ça fait beaucoup de l'arrivée en replay
ça fait trop ou mais bon d'un autre côté
moi ce que je me suis là tu alors pas en
fait ce soit je faisais le live de
gibraltar soit je commençais à bosser
pour préparer une vidéo
j'aurais film est probablement après le
stream mais je me suis dit que c'était
peut-être plus sympa perso comme les
vidéos d'analystes de partie on peut
tout le temps faire y en a souvent que
c'était plus sympa finalement de suivre
gibraltar en direct et pour les gens de
le voir en replay
c'était mon avis après ce ça change
enfin ça change un petit peu ce ça
permet de profiter un petit peu de la
cub ce que des parties finalement on
peut toujours en trouver
après on se permet d'avoir votre avis
notre avis de disputer un petit peu mais
moi je pensais moi je perso je pensais
que c'était l'opportunité de voilà quand
même une finale de gibraltar c'était fin
j'ai un collègue 2004 qui trouvent pas
assez ou qu'on s'inscrit au club alors
c'est dans ce lien ça leur a fait
inscrire qui va s'ouvrir
quels conseils donnerais un débutant
progresser aux échecs 20 de bien
apprendre les bases c'est-à-dire les
finales et finales et finales toutes les
finales comment mater au début enfin
comment faire les maths de l'escale truc
très simple jusqu'à savoir plus ou moins
gagner des finales de pions simple pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir simplifier les
positions donc à prendre tous les
basiques des finales finale avec une
pièce mineurs après tu te barres un
petit peu comme on fait avec roy
foudroie cavaliers tout ça et dans un
deuxième temps après se faire un petit
répertoire
enfin répertoire c'est un grand mot mais
essayer de jouer des ouvertures ou tu
comprend un petit peu les idées
genre tu apprends un peu l'italienne où
t'apprends l'espagnol l'écossaise et
puis tu essayes d'un peu de de connaître
un peu les plans pour réussir à te
perfectionner dans le milieu du jeu
d'une ouverture au début
alors flat bet poker il est dit que les
live super intéressant mais conca passé
commun qualificatif pour débutants et
ouais mais parce que le problème en fait
c'est que tu as deux types de public
le type public vraiment débutants
débutants et le public qui qui joue un
peu déjà aux échecs et le propre 1 entre
guillemets le problème c'est que sur les
lèvres des chèques tu as quand même plus
des gens qui joue un petit peu qu'ils
sont vrais alentours de 1300 à 1400 1500
déjà donc ils sont plus complètement
débutants et ça reste quand même le gros
des gens qui regardent les lives d'échec
on sans compter les joueurs beaucoup
plus fort mais ceci explique cela
on est 24 il reste cinq minutes à l'est
on peut peut-être on peut peut-être
atteindre l'est peut-être atteindre les
30 joueurs ce soir allez on se bat on se
bat on se bat fond
on se bat à fond
marc dans quatre minutes un soyez prêts
ne ratez pas la première ronde
c'est là qu'on peut aussi créer des
surprises 1d x gens rentrent pas
forcément bien dans le tournoi le mec
est beaucoup mieux classé que toi et
bout le piège et gris qui sent qu'il est
chaud ce soir c'est quand même bien pour
les finales de base c'est important les
exercices tactiques doit être efficace
aussi oui évidemment il faut aussi que
tu faisais des exercices tactiques
notamment inscrire en prendre un coup
or sur ce point comme je crois que tu en
inde ailleurs avec ce contreur faire des
tactiques c'est aussi très important au
final basique tactique et à prendre une
ou deux ouvertures histoire d'avoir des
idées une avec les blancs une avec les
noirs pour un peu voir des idées de
milieu de jeu déjà ça ne peut être que
bénéfique
donc donc donc encore trois minutes et
on va attaquer notre tournoi
j'aime bien moi ce tournoi toujours un
rendez vous qui me qui me fait plaisir
toujours content quand on fait notre
tournoi alors c'est quoi le nom du
tournoi bitstream février mais il faut
absolument que tu soit inscrit dans le
club literie main pour le trouver je
crois que les gens attendre arena kings
web que tu veux jouer l'aréna king's
possible mais on ne tournait plus
impasse du 3 + 2 on joue entre nous
j'aime bien d'un tournoi
quel serait pour toi je comprends pas
trop ta question est flat beat flatte
d'être poker le site web design êtres
humains qui est bon on va suivre ta
partie en premier en tête un petit peu
un petit peu te regarde et on n'a jamais
eu quelqu'un à 300 lots on n'a jamais eu
quelqu'un à 300 lots dans ces tournois
on va voir ce que ça donne 300 lots
s'est pas non plus c'est pas lourd j'ai
envie de dire c'est pas lourd 300 lots
on estime que l'effacement comme
surévalué ou sous-évaluent le de combien
de points par rapport à un vrai
classement à 13 points comme il est un
peu bizarre parisienne player parce que
je trouve que quand et 1200 1300 tu es
plutôt sous-évalué c'est un joueur les
mecs à 1200-1300 j'aurais peut-être plus
tôt à 1400 1500 fidh plus pas gérer ça
comme ça et les gens qui ont 2005 2006
2007 sont plutôt surévalué donc chez
paillasse et pas tout à fait linéaire
entre le classement trois points comme
et le classement fidh s'est pas linéaire
du tout à bientôt mathieu car c'est
dommage que tu puisses paraissait pour
le live comme il semble que tu avais
très envie de suivre en live
eh bien c'est raté désolé dommages à une
prochaine
donc
neymar dans une minute on va voir ce
qu'on va voir ça c'est un compte 25
joueurs donc c'est un peu le truc
parfait ces espèces de d'élimination
directe va faire cinq sur cinq pour
gagner je pense ce soir est ce que
quelqu'un est capable de tout gagner
réponse dans un peu moins d'une heure à
mon avis réponse dans un peu moins d'une
heure
non on est assez on est assez nombreux
mais chez pas en fait si on est sûr tu
as comme tu es ou pas faut que j'aille
vérifier twitter nice nous n'étions pas
au niveau de ses missions page c'est
parce qu'ils mettent en fait je ne sais
pas ce qui passe non ce n'est pas nous
ce n'est pas d'où nous ne sommes pas
sûrs heures sur thiès comme tu es ni
sympathie ni sympa
nous sommes vraiment entre nous ce soir
là j'ai perdu le chat du coup qu'est ce
que je suis en train de faire n'importe
quoi attention que le match d'hier ça va
quand même les cds des traces entre unis
va allez c'est parti c'est parti c'est
parti alors j'avais dit qu'on suivait le
joueur qui avait le plus petit et l'eau
et il l'est plus il est où ma main je
vois plus à l'effort fait peut-être
alain il n'y est plus ben je sais pas je
sais pas bon alors on va suivre au
hasard on va suivre
ben tiens on va suivre le duc de
normandie nous disait qu'il était chaud
le duc de normandie
on va voir s'il est vraiment chaud donc
une est indienne la vente avec h3 ici se
sont mis à l'essai reviennent avec avec
les vidéos peut-être donc à 5 assez bien
joué il veut il veut gagner la casse et
5 pour le cavalier à quatre partenaires
un peu soupçonnant parce que normalement
tu veux plutôt faire un plan avec des 3a
3b 4 pour chasser un jour le cavalier et
en faisant à 4 en fait ça ça donne les
cases des quatre et c5 tout bêtement
j'imagine un coup comme cavalier 17
rabbin qui ont ces cinq peut-être poussé
f 5 pouces f5 avant d'ailleurs comme ça
on menacera f4 qu'avec ses pattes je
sais pas si mes d'un carillon c5 puis si
je pousse f5 direct j'aurais hésité
en tout cas c'est assez sympa les blancs
ont donné beaucoup de casse cou à quatre
c'est vraiment mauvais j'espère que j'y
voyais que tu joues comme du tourin qui
a pas eu un bug
j'espère qu'il ya eu un bond à 6 à 1 sur
1 6 6 est bon et il ya un nombre impair
donc je dis ouais qui y est pas mon
leader du tournoi donc le petit foucher
5 et dames 8 donc bien jouer et
maintenant peut-être que l'on menace
même avec les noirs de fer à chlef 4
puis à fils g5 pour choper le fou tout à
fait possible je sais pas mais ce fou
peut se retrouver enfermé après faut
calculer vador c'est ce qui fait f4 et
en fait ils mal acquis a juste choisi tu
choisi le mauvais plan
le coup à 4 est vraiment très mauvais et
la main et là se prendra fils et puis on
prend g5 et va voir une pièce de moi
alors après il peut quand même essayé de
résister 1 il faut peut-être qui faisait
pas moins qu'ils prennent qui peint qui
sacrifient à un moment et est restée
dans la partie mais en fait j'ai cinq la
dame ira navigant h5 après les noirs
attaque plus naturellement allait droit
dans les escales indiennes peut-être sur
pions prend fou qui tente f5 pour fermer
le jeu et du coup et du coup bien joué
de la part d'ubs de romandie qui joue ef
et qui se libère la case 2,5 pour le
cavalier qui laisse pas les blancs
fermer le jeu maintenant il va sacrifier
mes pions prend cavaliers prend va avoir
une case de cinq fantastiques pour un
cavale une casse ces cinq fantastiques
pour l'autre cavale et une pièce de plus
il commence par d'alger si ça il laisse
pas de cavalier aussi simplement parce
que ces clous et est maintenant il va
pouvoir amener le cavalier le cingo je
je je donne des idées en général un mais
c'est pour montrer à quel point les
blancs ont laissé ont laissé le terrain
pour il a fait 3 qui est aussi très bien
joué il va il va commencer à réseauter
le roi et il va placer ses pièces quitte
à petit on va quand même regarder c'est
parti jusqu'à la fin parce que ça joue
assez bien peut-être peut même mettre le
foin 5 du coup sûr échec à voir damages
5 aussi très bien joué il menace le pion
h4 y protège le pion f3 qui maintenant
été attaqués et du cavalier 5 d'amour h4
cavale et gk tout arrive le fou qui va
le fou qui peut venir cinq ce cavalier
l'annoncé 5
les blancs et les noirs vraiment toutes
les cases à je pense fou et s'inquiète
et puis du cavalier f6 échec quand le
roi vient h3 et ça va ça va ça va
craquer en faire rage trois cavaliers
chèque est encore cavalier e 6 mai
peut-être après dame g4 échec et mat les
courageux trois cavaliers f6 cavaliers
six dames g4 maths ça paraît être ce qui
va se passer car il y aussi seul courant
à moins que et dames g4 maths et
victoire du dedans on dit donc ce ce
poids 4 qui aura été très préjudiciable
très très mal joué autant à je crois
qu'en juin là je pense qu'il ya
peut-être plus joué avec fougue et 5g
cas je pense qu'elle est d'aider variant
dans cet esprit là mais à 4 très très
mal
je sais pas exactement un truc avec h3c
parce que je joue mais je pas si c'est
ça existe exactement comme ça mais bon
c'était mal joué allez on va aller voir
le favori le favori qui nous a joué une
grotte et qui a vite gagné une qualité
ouais ben là grob qui a déjà pas mal
marché en pro de chez slick pour maxime
lagarde est là pour le moment ça marche
pas mal pour pour pour czech 30,54
pourquoi cas très mauvais pas de
simplement ce que tu donnes les cases b
quatre et c5 ce que j'ai expliqué un tu
pourras voir en replay mais tu donnes
les 15 à quatre et c5 et c'est ça le
problème de ces bkt c5
ça laisse la case des quatre n'a encore
pu ça casse c'est cinq ans fait encore
pire tu laisses tes casse je laisse les
cases et en plus ce n'est pas vraiment
utile
ce qui veux pas faire à 4 lui même donc
tu perds un coup en plus au passage ça a
tout du mauvais coup perd un temps perd
perd des cases passé ton tour était plus
fort si je puis me permettre
bon la manade chaix 30,54 il va pouvoir
aller faire du dam b5 damas six dans le
peut-être cavaliers des six pour essayer
de défendre mais ça devrait craquer
rapidement
knight est d'ailleurs ces cinq aussi
inquiète déjà peut-être c5 maintenant
d'ailleurs qu'elle bouge pas pour garder
la théorie un manager ce pas là vraiment
que je joue donc mais peut-être un truc
avec fous j'ai cinq possibles j'ai pas
vraiment te tais guinée là dessus que je
joue pas des quatre que je vous
palestinienne je connais un peu quelques
trucs mais n'est pas très bien cette
variante là mais je pense que j'ai eu
avec fougue et 5 normalement dans celle
là mais je ne suis pas je passe sur / en
fait ne joue juste page 3 en fait je
joue juste fou eu de rock et je voulais
variant de classiques on a fait toute
une série sur les variantes classique
sur youtube en fait tu peux jouer la
variante classique tout à fait jouable
ou une baïonnette ou quelque chose
d'autre
ce sera peut-être plus simple en plus
plus accessible mais oui ce jeu avec un
choix seront jouées avec g4
mais cette suroît b8 pour venir stopper
le pion on va faire damas si ces dames à
8 mater sur wade huit mois ferme et huit
dames la dame à 6 et damas huit matches
sera imparable c'est fini
même sur deux en france et 6 heures on à
damas huit matches quand même même la
dame en de la propre a donc partie
gagnée pièce 30 54 et on va voir la
dernière partie c'est chaud c'est chaud
c'était à partir des années on acquiesce
de plus pièce de plus pour les noirs
mais alors à temps parce que les noirs
sont classés 1148 donc là on est un peu
de sueur une surprise là non non on n'a
presque plus pour les blancs non mais je
suis complètement à l'ouest des fois on
est appelé the bus pour les blanches je
veux mélange cc c'est dingue quoi quand
changer une partie à l'offre au bout
d'un moment c'est difficile de voir mais
oui c'est juste us de plus pour les
blancs et position complètement
écrasante
heureusement je me reprends rapidement
donc à pas du tout surprise en cours là
un truc marrant ses tours ses deux fois
ci c'est bon mais c'était marrant là ça
suffit il faut replacer les pièces
peut-être c'est de sortir le roi dont
les noirs pose encore quelques petits
problèmes à les échanges les tours
férois c5 quelques petits problèmes
pratiques allait jouer un peu plus vite
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe échange les tours
ferron à ses 5 s'est approché des pions
créé un pion passé c'est pas fini fini
fini encore il aurait pu encore encore
créé des soucis dans l'allée vers la
deuxième partie donc vous voulez voir la
partie du joueur le moins bien classé du
truc je crois qu'on n'a plus jamais un
joueur avec un si petit classement 348
commence par quatre ce trafic immonde
synthois mensuel ouais c'est tous les
premiers jeudis du mois tous les
premiers jeudis du mois
il ya un jeudi c'est le premier à le
tournoi 20h35 on va faire des 5
on va voir comment je vous jouez à 348
chu curieux comment il va s'en sortir
là c'est une défense française et noir
vont jouer avec ses 5 qui a réalisé ici
c'est le cavalier c3 pas très bien placé
normalement voudra voir le pion en c3
pour soutenir la chaîne de pions et là
avec le quart alliance et 3 le truc
c'est que le pion des cas très
vulnérables et donc le pur u5 aussi mais
bon ça peut il faut qu'ils tiennent
champion des quatre mais là on menace
déjà peut-être du pion prend et le pion
aux 5 pourrait tomber et aussi la dame
qui peut venir verbe et 6 pour aller
s'en prendre à b2 pour le moment ça
tient de justesse sur puis on prend il y
aura fou prend là j'ai peur que je sais
pas quel point il va prendre mais je
pense c'était le bon coup finalement de
prendre en c5 plus la position mais mais
c'est vrai que le canadien c3 est très
mal placé compliqué compliqué pour pour
dire oui mais il se débrouille quand
même pas mal 1 par rapport à son lots
j'ai pas 300 je sais pas vraiment ce que
ça vaut mais il joue un truc qui
ressemble un peu à quelque chose quand
même
donc c'est plutôt bien et peut-être
mettre le web peut-être le fond de ou en
b 5 peut-être pourquoi pas en bessin fr
rock vont essayer de se battre quoi il
peut essayer de se battre pour le moment
en tout cas il n'a pas perdu après mes
quatre là il perd juste un pion bon son
adversaire aurait peut-être pu le
prendre à voir mais bon il fait cavalier
17 tirs visent le pion aux cinq donc qui
est faible et le pion b4 est en prise
donc c'est très bien joué aussi la faut
déjà peut-être faire du dam eux deux
elle a du coup il perd le purell 5 et là
il ya tout qui tombe
il ya même un point intermédiaire
marrant qui était peut-être envisageable
après j'aurais probablement pris
mesdames à 5 pour aller faire dame ses
trois échecs et reprendre le pion comme
ça après c'était pour le pour la beauté
du geste
mais là il commence à être très mal dit
ouais
donc fou et 2
il se développe cette sphère rock food
et 7 retours c8 quelque chose comme ça
c'est mal engagé
c'est quand même très mal engagé 7 kg 6
ou cake pas après près pareil b6 fou
bessette tu vois il me poussait une
poussée e5 éventuellement d'un mes fils
aussi très bien mais là tout est bien
qualifié 6 on échange les dames au
prochain il menace car aliev trois
échecs aussi au passage donc il faut il
faut protéger la dame mais c'est vrai
que dans mes fils du coup avec le petit
piège contre un joueur mal classés ce
pas mal joué après faut pas tenter des
pièges de partout hein mais bédard même
si c'était un bon coup et ça permet de
ça permet de finir la partie avec la
petite tactique cavaliers pour un f3 la
découverte sur la dame dame prend des
quatre qui suis je pense qu'on peut
passer à une autre partie mais jouer
capacim a joué un stratégiquement
finalement alors allez voir cette de
baisse contre le charpentier
alors on sait pas trop ce qui s'est
passé pour celle de baisse mais ça va
être intéressant puisqu'il a n'a plus
beaucoup de temps je passe qui ce qui
leur arrivait ils ont mutuellement part
à la réflexion au début de la partie et
ils se sont offert du temps donc on se
retrouve en une six structures de pion
par nom de type karo kann avec une une
position qui va être avantageuse pour
les blancs forcément toujours ses petits
avantages non de ces structures
d'options type k rockhal mais ça se joue
ça se joue pour pour les noirs que ça va
c'est solide après il ya le fou ans et 8
k est toujours mal placé ma foi réussir
à reprendre le centre un moment x ou y
mais charpentier qui se bat pas mal il
va prendre le fou donc il va reprendre
de a et il va falloir réussir à
développer ce fou de cases blanches pour
les noirs les mécaniques 6 6e et qui
consolide un peu à cinq je pense qu'il
veut mettre un pion h6 maintenant et on
peut pas jouer h6 nous mêmes parce que
parce qu'il ya le clouage là j'imagine
qu'il va se prendre du damage quatre
fous j'ai 5 mai d'un match cap tête on a
le temps de faire h6 donc fouet f4 et là
c'est peut-être l'occasion de jouer cinq
jeux riom en vidéo et 5 perso avec les
noirs rendre le pion et joue un peu sur
sur le roi mal placé au centre c'est
plus un coup de blitz que deux parties
longues ça parce que parce que les
blancs doivent avoir le temps de faire
un grand quai de s'en sortir mon but
c'est pas mal de retrouver de l'activité
qui est des cinq mais c'est vrai que
c'est un peu short way sur grand roque
tête damas cinq maintenant tu es allé
faire damas un qui allait oued à ma 5e
c'est pas mal je pense comme coup
essayer d'aller créer un peu le désordre
attaqué la base sur damas 5,6 férois
bien peut-être cavaliers b4 essayer de
le ramener les pièces comme ça ça me
paraît très intéressant et sur damas un
qui prend des cinq peut-être tout
reprend 2,2 pour menacer matin
quoique y aurait juste 3 b 1 i'm here
hoibian y aurait pu durer la pièce sont
des cinq qui traîne donc peut-être moi
je serai damas cinq ici d'aller créer de
l'incertitude de l'autre côté après les
blancs doivent tenir mais
mais bon on essaye on joue le va-tout on
peut jouer leur va tout il fait fou aux
6h 6 direct sans réfléchir
peut-être un petit coup droit bien quand
même pour semi sécuriser tout ça ou
allez directement attaqué de l'autre
côté ça se calcule aussi du dam le 5 mai
à tf6 avoir un autre coup qui peut être
marrant mais plus pour le fun c'est tour
h4 paraît d'activer la tour dont il fait
cavaler f4 pragmatique savait qu'il veut
aller prendre l'a essayé de faire du dha
me 5,4 et maintenant petit à petit les
quasiment plus en plus faibles sur damas
cinq maintenant il ya damev 6 et
maintenant il ya des rêves 6 et il va
devoir se barrer avec le roi fait juste
3 bien tranquille il consolide la fedama
5 un peu tard je pense même s'il aurait
été mal quand même hein mais du coup il
ya d'alger cette dame prend un f16 qui
va être très pénible puisque ça va
gagner un pion tout bêtement à la dessus
je pense un petit coup de tourin voilà
une ou l'autre on retire des cases de
fuite du roi sens là aussi souvent
expliqué avec fab est sûre fou aussi son
avoir tout reprendre six tours prend 1,6
d'un match 8 échecs et on gratte à tours
à huit donc sap de celle qui va
l'emporter
celle de celle qui est en train de filer
vers la victoire
le charpentier qui voit la tour pranger
si cela a minima enfin prises et d'un
match était dame prend 1,8 et rideaux on
prend 2,17 maintenant cavalier e 4 il ya
tout qui rentrent il ya tout qui rentre
la fourchette
ces dames c'est tour de plus en plus
d'âme tour c'est un matériel qui
favorise d'attac
donc on sait pas trop pris la fef 3 il
aurait juste pu faire d'un problème
français 6 échecs mais bon c'est pas
grave
seul truc qui pourrait arriver c'est un
espèce de perpète avec damas fin d'un
mât si ça ça ça pourrait enfin là il va
juste y avoir match mais on va dire le
seul micro pf qui aurait pu avoir c'est
un père pète comme ça je sais pas
pourquoi il fait pas mates en un effet
peut-être exprès d'ailleurs pour
s'amuser
donc c'est gagner il reste encore
quelques parties allez on va voir des
buts en contre roy et van roy evans
était plutôt evans 75 de paris
probablement est roi et van roy evans
qui est en train de battre débutant
puisqu'il à tour de plus là et la main
en dames et tours de plus ça va gagner
tranquillou qu'est-ce qu'on a encore on
amine haine contre chez ça on va aller
voir les favoris alors tout leur poser
mais y'a les tours c'est un plus et
peut-être à l'eshop espion elle fait
tour cd va choper celui-là l'odm a chopé
suis là c'est pas fini c'est pas fini
tour ces deux bons il va récupérer ces
quatre noms mais ça doit être quasi
gagnant pour les noirs quand même mais
faut encore finir comprendre ces quatre
peut-être revenir en c2 avec la tour ont
assez du tour eu deux effets tour c6
quand même très envie d'aller s'en
prendre option que demande si on veut
pas même ramener le roi comme ça en fait
pour passer en g2 est allé après rentrer
en force de partout d'être tour cédant
en premier ouais c'est ce qui va faire
ok maintenant rage et devrait est passé
comme ça de ce côté là le foot va devoir
venir en e1 ramène le roi ayman entoure
ces deux ans qu'il fallait ramener le
fou en juin penser quand même perdu 1
parce que la maroc et tour deux tours
prend c'est fini 60e plongé trois qui
tombait donc h4 donc tout y tomber de
chasse 30,54 qui l'emportent ou pour le
moment les leaders font de boulot les
dont deux sur deux on pourrait assister
à une finale 7 de 7 contre 7 de baisse
moi j'appelle toursel the same way c'est
celle de baisse mais jamais sur scène
the same je sais pas pourquoi c'est une
habitude
c'est une habitude et on va regarder
contre le duc de normandie du concept de
baisse je sais pas pourquoi je l'appelle
celle de sel j'essaie à chaque fois je
l'appelle comme ça c'est impossible de
savoir pourquoi je fais ça mais oui
c'est celle de baisse
après calais front va rentrer dans une
slave pour ceux qui ont je pense cdpa
bon je pense cdo des bons ça devrait
être jouable mais le fait que ça libère
le fou de cases blanches on n'a pas
parlé malheureusement la master class 1
pas eu le le temps de le temps d'en
parler un malheureusement mai mais dans
ces structures slave tu veux pas tu veux
pas prendre trop tôt quoique peut-être à
la place de fouet cette ouais je crois
qu'il va rater avec foued cinq ici dame
b trois cavaliers 17 d'armes prohibées
cette tourbe et huit dames français six
tours caen b 2 je crois qu'il ya un truc
dans cet esprit là d'après il faudrait
réviser mais là du coup ça peut
ressembler à des positions qu'on aurait
dans des camps bride spring avec la
prise en d5
ouais ça transpose ne se transpose pas
forcément dans les meilleures variantes
ce sera juste pas forcément dans les
variantes les plus non mais c'est pas
mauvais mais c'est en comptant les
variantes les plus il est plus agressif
qui ont le plus de devenuns ce qu'en
fait là tu peux dans cette position là
en fait après si tu peux faire cavalier
f3 en fait tu es là tu as trois
variantes cavaliers b17 th 6 août à
dépenser 4 mais c'est un peu venimeux en
fait
enfin le niveau cadet millions de partir
au niveau 1
mais c'est pas mal non je sais pas du
tout ce qu'il a fait cette cep de baisse
du coût b 5a 5b 4
donc
bon du coup ils se retrouvent avec un
pion isolé avec les noirs
il se retrouve avec un pion isolé avec
les noirs en d5 et c'est un pur isolé
qui doit pas être qui doit pas être fou
fou peut-être tour des seins et c'est
forcément un peu mieux pour les blancs
cette histoire là après c'était pas si
énorme parce qu'il a il a quand même
l'activité il se bat fours b1 qui a aidé
4 et peut-être fou ces deux fauves et 3
d'ailleurs pour venir attaquer le pion
peut-être fou c'est de fouler 3 bon là
fouquereau v4 j'y crois pas du tout mais
bon il joue peut-être sur karen ie5 et
le fait d'avoir des fourchettes pénible
en 17
j'aurais même pas envisagées fou
provoque a tant fait pour dire la vérité
mais ne donne pas un mauvais jeu
stratégiquement c'est pas le truc que tu
regardes mais il obtient poil d'activité
avec son cavalier vrai c'est d'un point
de vue pratique pas évident à jouer avec
les noirs
après il doit y avoir quelque chose
c'est sûr mais ouais c'est pas
c'est pas mal fait bonfoh à six dames
ces deux ça ira at a que 4 et l'âme des
deux ouais pourquoi pas
c'est un poil oreilles ce truc key 17
qui est très pénible nom fu b5 c'est le
truc que j'aurais joué comme ça suffit
les 17 qui veut prendre en 17 ans fait
échanger ça doit aller
mesdames dessin quoi ils gardent les
gars de saïx menace ils menacent dame
prend le 4 mars a créé bien dame ces
deux et il va aller encaisser le plus 4
en toute tranquillité vraiment bien je
la parle de normandie avec ce coup-franc
cavaliers 5 était vraiment qu'ils
étaient vraiment sympas tosh maintenant
peut-être il peut faire d'amd 5 le
retour est allé jouer sur sur le pion à
5 qui va rester en prise en fin de
variantes voir grosse partie il a dit
qu'il était chaud ce soir il a dit qu'il
était chaud il est chaud patate
il est chaud patate hockey tête il faut
prendre prendre et faire tomber un mythe
juste à mes tombé sur un problème avec
le fou qui on peut pas faire ça non plus
dans ces cas-là faut peut-être joué un
coup de fouet mais alors quel coup de
fou faut trouver un coup de fouet il n'a
pas un coup de fouet un coup de fouet à
peut-être fou et 8 quoi un peu
désespérée mais ok tour des huit c'est
peut-être un as et un coup de fouet à
tour des huit ce que sur tarn prend ici
la tour prends des 1 et surtout reprend
emprise et c'est bien joué et ça m'est
complètement ratée aux commentaires
cette petite tactique sympa tâche que
sur dame prend prise prizee la fouille 8
s est bien vu bien vu bien vu alors
après ce qu'on peut faire du cavalier
ces quatre cavaliers c4 et cavaliers des
six alors il faut tenter g5 je pense à
aimer sur g5 validé si ces menaces tout
reprend 8 échecs à yahia
mais bon quel idée si cette fois les
fouines et de l'autre côté mais
peut-être même du fou et ça m'a l'air la
cata cette baisse qui pourtant n'est
trouvé le joli tour des huit mais
malheureusement c'est un poil short
nigel j'ai envie de dire ouais c'est
short damien il va faire à 6 et puis il
va y avoir échec échec et non c'est bien
joué c'est bien joué c'est bien le h4
plus flash 5 plus forte ce qui va les
jouer avec h4 mais il va prendre dès
maintenant il va falloir avec les blancs
bloquer le roi et l'emporter alentours
tour g8 magnifique les des pièces
blanches le travail à merveille
cavaliers pros avec cet échec 3 7 tours
j'ai sept matches dur dur pour cette de
best ducs de normandie chaud patate
belle partie alors est-ce qu'on va avoir
deux surprises et en europe cet arc deux
surprises que roy evans est en train de
surprendre chef 30 54 et c'est une des
premières fois d'habitude les favoris
dans ces tournois et ils marchent sur
l'eau sont l'habitude de remporter lier
les deux grosses surprises pourraient
voir une grosse partie aux volailles
c'est quand même dame de moins donc on a
du mal à imaginer comment à roy evans
rattrapage sur les mêmes du cavalier f5
dimanche de la tour on échange des
pièces jetées changes après le flou pour
qu'ils restent plus rien mon choix c'est
ce genre d'échangé 130 54 garde les
pièces mais ça va ça va pas ça va pas
tenir sa pas tenir deux cent cinquante
ans cette histoire là ces dames deux
mois il va rester deux rondes
ça va être tendu est-ce que les favoris
auront le temps de remonter ou pas même
pas sûr
c'est vrai c'est tournant là tournoi
compliqué tournoi compliqué pour
l'instant favori ne font pas respecter
la loi
j'ai pas quand il marque camaïeu 4 juste
des parois evans est hyper ça il va s'en
vouloir un quand même un avantage
matériel substantielle ram un poil pour
gagner erwan un petit peu pour gagner
nos matchs 5 et dame prend et 2 quand
même finir par le faire tourbe et de à
l'est rien on finit sa fille ni moi ça
pour acheter cash 3 et matt d'emprunt f2
et il a gagné par abandon en troisième
ronde
elle aidera démonte pas fini alors là
ses qualités de plus c'est la tour va
être vraiment forte parce que parce que
parce que les pions sont un peu décimés
sur l'échiquier mais il ya des petites
fourchette lecavalier toujours très
dangereux en blitz
non kate on prend des 5 mai la cie et le
cavaly se retrouve en diagonale par
rapport au roi
donc ça va nous donner du temps après
tour f5 je suis pas sûr ils laissent le
roi sera étiez peut-être tout racisme
amenant avec elle ses deux pieds prend à
3 mais on doit pouvoir faire c'est sûr
qu'il est prend à trois on peut pas
choper le canal direct ce que tu crois
b2k et ces cas donc il vient avec la
tour est maintenant en droit b2 et on
enferme le cavalier et débutants qui va
battre dispatch là malheureusement les
noirs ne peuvent pas voir de contre jeu
parce que le roi peut pas passer donc il
va pousser un pion on va pousser l'autre
et puis on va aller gratter des pions
voilà ça ça va aller tranquillement pour
pour débutants 71
on aimerait bien avoir un abandon quand
même un pour les gens qui pour les gens
qui attendent pour les prochaines rondes
voilà c'est chose faite
il reste deux parties on va être obligé
d'aller vers la table une pourvoir à on
va avoir du goût des appariements
croisés j'ai bien envie de voir wiseman
contre 7 de baisse à leon soit un petit
on se suit celle de ben est à fond
bon festival jacques à l'ouverture wave
and age ou l'espagnol il joue l'espagnol
est ce un croc damev 6 kg en recettes
j'imagine donc ces trois il veut
préparer des 4 et des cats pour le
moment il peut pas jouer parce que les
pièces noires sont placés cavaliers c6
le fou ces cinq ans pêche aux blancs de
pousser des 4 c'est intéressant là le
développement noir il va pouvoir
peut-être m le fou en g 4 après qu'a
rédigé six cavaliers f4 l'effet h5
il envoie tous les niveaux en force la
selle de cette cep de baisse sur roue à
chien fou pour un f2 un réel plus à f2
qui peut traîner il ya le fluage croix
qui freine sur g3 et adam pranger 3
airwatch de bouffon prend f2 en fout g4
il s'en fout les pions c'est de la merde
pour se [ __ ] en l'air de ça faisait
mal quand même un éclat casse g3 après
donc évidemment on peut pas prendre
parce qu'on va reprendre du pillon et ça
va faire mal
elle est blanche séparés sur ce point
yves dequidt règne à tous qui traînent
difficile
c'est difficile fouet 3
on il est noir cela devrait bien c'est
que de la défense ou contre attaque ou
bas ça dépend des ouvertures que tu
joues en fait tu avais ouverture où tu
défends d'ouverture où tu tues ans qui a
raté sa neuvième leblanc vachement c'est
juste qu'il va choisir un plan je sais
pas quel plan il faut choisir là mais là
encore il faudra garder dans la théorie
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut jouer de la
voir une manière de répondre pour
réaliser des bases de données en fait
pour vous dire exactement comme c'est
pas mon répertoire une nouvelle fois et
que je joue pas du tout ça c'est pas
évident de vous dire exactement comment
répondre mais c'est clair que le truc de
jouer avec ces trois pour faire des
cathares tout arrive jamais à faire des
cats étaient pas très efficace il faut
regarder il faut aller chercher dans la
théorie
faut aller chercher dans la théorie pour
avoir pour avoir la réponse mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que le plan des blancs
n'étaient pas du tout du tout du tout
efficace façon jouer ses trois pour les
d4 quand tu peux pas enchaîner par des
cats et pas c'est pas la joie mais du
coup comme les noirs ont raté foot pro f
2 comme les noms ont raté fou prend un
f2 en fait la position s'équilibre on va
jouer sur la colonne ouverte
peut-être faire du fou c'est de fouler 3
replacer l'oeuf ou sur cette diagonale
il sera quand même mieux placé le cac
gagnant hk temps f 5 ans la dame f4
c'est une semi menace a poussé deux
foulées 3 et tout cas l'idée c'est que
sur g iii et vous jouez h4 j'imagine
peut-être joué d'un noeud 3 avec l'idée
sûr d'apprendre jouer pions prend pour
renforcer les casses faible après faire
cavaler h quatre cavaliers f5 même ont
pris deux pions doublé c'est pas si
grave nous peut-être tout liquider sur
la colonne des pour rentrer avec la dame
peut être un autre plan c'est ce que
c'est si grave si la dass et le carré
les liens ici je sais pas j'aimerais y
croire et vannes et écoutent nos
commentaires ce que je voudrais c'est un
joueur positionnelle maintenant oui
avant non 9,4 au caire tel budget 3
juste avec les plans et précis prise par
l'entourent d1 pour aller jouer tour 17
très belgique
on va voir peut-être un peu arrêtez de
commenter trop de quoi là après le roy
evans a bien joué parce que quand on
commenté pas et je veux quand même très
bien jusqu'au bout de coups qu'on qu'on
recommande un peu voir ce qui se passe
quand on dit plus rien si je voulais qu
auquel je pense remarque là je pense par
exemple chose pour dire la vérité
mais les blancs sont très très bien il
contre la colonne la colonne des noms
c'est une belle position pour les blancs
on va avoir beaucoup de mal pour les
cavaliers h4 pour les têtes en f5 la
lekié tour des six et le coût auquel je
pensais mais bon il n'était pas trop dur
à voir parce que menace le cavalier mais
c'était pas si bons d'heure parce que là
il va devoir faire pousser deux
cavaliers c5 est quelqu'un arrive à
revenir aussi c'est dieu c'est non mais
je pense qu'ils se débrouillent tout
seuls
c'est juste mais la tour des six c4 et
c5 c'est bien jouer il va réussir à
remettre le cavalier e 6 e tatou rond 8
et il va grâce réactive et naïve ou
cabaye h4 mais bon là encore c'est un
poids assez logique c'est de venir en
aide 5
le truc c'est qu'on a du mal à rentrer
sur la septième en face que les deux
cavaliers ils vont couvrir 17-17 c7 et
a6 est couvert aussi donc on peut pas
vraiment rentrer sur la septième en plus
le cavaliere eux aussi s'il va couvrir
le pion g7 après peut-être tenter un
truc avec f4 a dû bouger mais une tour
c6 maintenant c'est pas pour rien le
fait qu'à 6 2 il doit y avoir une raison
là il a dû rater un épisode fort ses
tours ses six tours c'est 7 mais il est
dû rater un truc quand même assez bien
donc il ya un truc que j'ai pas dû voir
pas facile de se concentrer sur les
parties des autres
ok maintenant lequel va se redire y
j'aimerais garder on ne sait pas si
grave non et je pense que ça ça doit
amener petit à petit vers une nulle
cette histoire après avoir un peut se
passer encore beaucoup de choses
vraiment il parle vous à tous les
cavaliers c'est cet échec et car il
prend ainsi cela par exemple qui gagne
immédiatement la partie
enfin gagné la partie j'exagère mais qui
gagne est un pion et c'est important je
remonterai mais quand j'expose
historique la calle c7 qui prend 1,6
c'était cadeau 1
c'était cadeau
voilà du coup les blancs ont essayé de
tout fermer faire annuler sa blondeur
sable honda alors que le duc est en feu
le dieu qui a dû gagner le duc doit être
un 4 sur 14 pourquoi j'ai pas le
classement par le duc est en feu le duc
est à 4 sur 4 leduc leduc marche sur le
tournoi ça à faire nuit donc c'est 7 de
baisse qui gagnera pas ce tournoi
puisque le duc à 4 sur 4 7 de baisse qui
va être à sif nuls ils seraient à 3 à 2
et demi donc il faut déjà plus gagné de
tournoi et save the beast est il
vraiment le bes voir ça répète les coûts
je pense qu'il va la forcer
c'était une partie en réel jus content
je recommanderais fortement de prendre
la nuit parce qu'à force de force et on
perd souvent en fut 1-3 puis pourquoi
pas de fracture f4 ça gagne pas pourquoi
ça gagnerait finalement tu crées même
pas de menaces en fait alors tu peux
jouer comme ça sue et ses dialectes et
blanc mais là apparemment il veut juste
attendre et faire un nul et karelia
4-way bien jouer enfin roi des deux mais
à un moment donné tu peux te faire
qu'est georges séparant akaba lieu trois
cas il ya en dessin qui te fait changer
tu perds tout ça arrive et ça plus d'une
fois de perdre est parti comme ça je
pense que le maître le quai ans et je
sais pas ce qu'il veut faire avec les
noirs
là je me serais bien car à lyon des 5
avec les blancs il pourrait y pourrait
essayer de vous voyez s'il avait faire
on va revenir un peu en arrière si là il
faisait cavalier des cinq ça pose un
problème parce qu'elles purent et fisc
et emprise on peut pas le protéger et si
on fait f5 il va y avoir pions prend en
admettant roi prend un prêt à peut-être
d'autres variantes 1 et puis enfants est
ok il ya peut-être cavaliers 7 qui tire
encore mais la maintenance et les blancs
qui presse parce qu'il ya des pions
peut-être faire j'ai quatre créé un pion
pas ch et il ya les pions là qui sont
sur blanc face est très chaude on
pourrait essayer de jouer la gagne avec
les blancs après faudrait calculer mais
on pourrait essayer
ça arrive vraiment quand les joueurs
press press press qui rate un petit truc
tactique comme ça et qu'on puisse après
jouer la gagne
bon elle a maintenant 7 de baisse qui va
ramener son cavalier vers des six images
in ses adversaires qui propose un peu
trop là nul c'est un peu dangereux de
proposer tout le temps à lui maintenant
il est mieux avec les blancs il peut
mettre le fou en f3 t'attaques le pion
h5 tu mets le roi a eu quatre pourquoi
t'es avait pas de gagner ça quand même
balle à tuer le foot à vii et une base
autre angle à situer le four f7 il va
finir par y avoir un jour sans qu'un
jour ou l'autre le cas il n'y a plus
qu'à bâle a poussé 6 et il se passe le
scénario le mauvais scénario celui
qu'ils attendent et c'est qu'à force de
force et ben tu perds mal à vous faire
fou à 4 et laisser l'adversaire en
zigzag lecavalier n'a plus de cases
toute façon tu es fou à 4 qui fait roi
là tu fais food et si tu fais fou dessin
qui fait roi décisif et 3,4 et tu va
encaisser le pion tranquillement et il
m'est pas l'adversaire
il y aune en semi exemple ce qui a le
plus rage 5 est ok maintenant droit à
quatre ou faux f3 les fouilles de
maintenant important pour faire [ __ ]
en c4 rsa cas l'air fous eux deux tu
prends ces 4 il va tomber il trouve pas
food qui a fait 3-3 a fait roi des 6,3
2,5 alors quelle galère et maintenant
fouet fc trésor à l'info à vii c'est
très important d'en faire ces quatre là
échec en hausse et le fait ses ses
cartes pour éviter la fourchette hausse
et le festival hors les finales les
enfants bosser les finales les enfants
s'il vous plaît vous faites mal à tonton
kevin quand vous jouez quand vous jouez
si mal et final c'est vous me faites mal
aux yeux en fait c'est une horreur un
cavalier des cinq échecs télé prend des
quatre ans mais quelle catastrophe
olala roy evans pourquoi tu me fais ça
non mais tu peux pas être si nul en
finale quand même norme au quai je suis
quand même sacrément nuit aux échecs en
général mais
mais là quand même c'est beaucoup roy
evans c'est quand même tout match quoi
même pour moi même pour moi c'est tout
mathus que tu as fait il peut peut-être
encore et c'est juste mais je peux même
plus comment tu es là c'était c'est un
festival de mauvais coups festival
international du mauvais coup auquel
vous avez assisté kg 3 bien joué mais
qu'il fasse froid g5 maintenant j'aurais
fait roi g5 la baisse car ils se
retrouvent en zigzag oh là là quelle
horreur parce qu'en fait tu fait
cavalier et reçu férois g5 qui te des
vis tu prends prend il fêté pour un f5
messi fait roi et vii battu fait
cavalier prend à 5 francs f5 héros
apprend f5 et tu fais nul direct bon ça
va faire nul quand même même pas sûr que
ça fasse lille monroe là les enfants les
enfants maintenant h6 attention succès
et 6 nuls faut faire un fils oh non il
ya cavaliers pros f6 non mais tu peux
pas non mais vous pouvez pas vous n'avez
pas le droit et ça c'est nul théorique
sais pas s'ils pouvaient la gagner mais
tu peux pas jouer avec 6 non mais
franchement on travaille et les mecs
faut bosser faut bosser faut bosser là
ya du boulot
l'iphone est même sacrifiant f5 mais je
leur parlais s'il veut pas sacrifier un
f5 il pouvait enfin bon si dans
l'optique il veut pas sacrifier un f5
férois g5 et tu tu prends tout quoi tu
ramasses suis là et tu ramasses autres
et c'est fini juste pour faire les
choses les plus propres mon possible
pour noirs du congrès contre roy evans
rôle evans qui à mon avis va
complètement craqué dans la partie ce
qu'il a dû se fatiguer à mort mais cette
finale elle a vraiment à la com com
écrivent dans le chat à la piquer les
yeux et c'est là la vraie le pic est
vraiment ouais là vous êtes sur la ccg
nans tv là cette finale comme une équipe
russe chinoise c'est toute la bonne
humeur s'est en allé kevin au bord du
suicide est là c'est cette finale elle a
fait très très mal cette finale elle m'a
fait très très mal
bon alors cette dernière partie il faut
que je me remette monsieur ducs de
normandie
si on forme que ça
merci le discorde suisse tournoi et si
l'on regardé la finale c'était quand
même quelque chose cette finale ils
n'écrivent pas le discorde arrêt c'est
bizarre les appariements la prod chelsea
qui viennent de sortir
mais je vais voir un peu les autres
équipes si c'est fort ou pas
est ce que ça donne les autres équipes
par curiosité
ok on va se faire détruire ils ont tous
réussi à mettre des bonnes équipes on
est les seuls à être vraiment affaiblis
donc ça va être l'horreur
ça va être l'horreur totale
ça va être compliqué ça va vraiment être
très compliqué
il ya que très peu d équipes qui n'ont
pas réussi à avoir quelque chose de
correct
mais on va se faire déchirer
on rhizosphère des chiens
fergani speedman dit qu'il faudrait
jouer les ouvertures comme des livres
les milieux comme un magicien et finale
comme une machine ouais je dois juste
une phrase pas pour ce pas grand-chose
interpréter
donc sur cette hollandaise n'a pas trop
su le début un message qui m'ont mis un
coup au moral avec leur avec leur fille
nahla l'instant ils ont mis un gros coup
au moral
je suis pas sûr que c'est très bien joué
par les noirs lacam laissé beaucoup de
terrain mais autant il va essayer de
tenir après c'est un peu comme les
ruines pour être juste a pas d'espacé
tout ça mais tu te défends à fond ça
faisait qui écrit signife alors qu'est
ce que tu as encore perdu saab de 7,7 de
best je peux vraiment c'est vrai quoi
qu'est ce qui t'arrive et celle de best
que s'est il passé pour toi
c'est en général s'est dit coûts
d'ouverture à 2008 le milieu du à 1700
une finale à 1200 et c'est à peu près ça
et ferment ce qu'on voit un essai de
base gagne pas le tournoi est celle de
veste cette baisse gagne pas le tournoi
ça c'est ça c'est sûr duc de normandie
est en feu dans une nouvelle de fabien
libye il a explosé lundi matin mais il
n'a pas fait un bon tournoi mais bon
aussi et vous revenez de d'australie
avec un gros jet lag et du coup c'était
peut-être un peu le tournoi de trop pour
fab
dans son long périple c'est pas toujours
évident de trouver la motive de jouer
aussi un camp les tournoi débute mal et
qu'on ne pouvait plus pour grand chose
au classement ce n'est pas pas toujours
évident de trouver la motive tout les
adversaires ne sont motivés puisqu'ils
peuvent jouer pour des normes ils font
des perfs
il joue contre un grand maître et tout
est donc pas à pas évident problème f6
tour eiffel un nouveau jeu pour le duc
de normandie peut-être un effet qui a
réussi ce qui est très bien aussi
un peu comme prévu roy evans après c'est
parti très longue en plus où il a raté
contre contre 7 de baisse il craque
faille craquent les joues solide la mer
c'est toujours très difficile celle
obtenue ce que tu as beaucoup de bien
jouer ça car elle joue vraiment bien du
dedans m'ont dit tu vraiment très bien
est-ce que je pense qu'à sport fus
rivaliser dans cette nouvelle vague de
joueurs banon enfin ça a été prouvé
quand il a joué il n'y a pas le niveau
quoi bon me firent jolie un petit un peu
trop fort le dit quoi faire d'un match
si ce live à mater dans les arrêts qu'il
est très très fort le duc à damas fuite
il va défendre de qualité 5 et pourrait
faire mon grillé c'est ici ça il ya quoi
une combinaison et un truc qui est des
cinq maintenant
et maintenant qu'est f6 échec et c'est
fini
ouais bien joué et bien joué bien je
ducs de normandie qui écrase et on a
vraiment très bien joué ce soir il est
en forme il était chaud il était chaud
voilà chef 30 54 ont valu va gagner non
qui va se refaire il va finir à 4 points
- la tour prend 17 c'est fini qui va
finir deuxième qu'est ce qui encore
comme parti alors allez voir des buts en
contre et vraie ville chérie vilches on
a beaucoup vu débutant aujourd'hui à
être débutant qui va gagner des buts en
71 seulement faire du dame j'ai trois
tours h4 maths ça ça va être gagné qui a
t'on encore jean pierre gosnat mah
contre eux je sais pas ce que je sais
pas qui est cette personne et puis j'ai
peur du regard de son pseudo ne sais pas
peut avoir des blagues des fois tu as f
4 ok il joue sur le clouage voudrait
peut-être plus juste faire dame français
cinq ans fait étrange mais ils n'ont
plus de temps aux 6 1
ils n'ont plus de temps et non plus 4
secondes trois secondes ça joue sur les
seconds adam français quatre là adam
prend à 4 gagnent la dame n'y a pas le
mât du couloir aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe cas l'erreur qui avait dame france
et 4 qui gagnait tout simplement à elle
fait mal je remonte le passage il a fait
dame prend 1,4 pour lui sur le mode du
couloir alors qu'il fallait prendre
juste la pièce est passé le tour d un
math
voilà maintenant la partie où elle en
est même à la maintenance et dames de
moi et aller tu prends aussi suprend des
5 et sa gagnerait sera une partie
derrière donc on va aller la voir à une
finale tour trois pions qu'on trouvera
fout là là on va pouvoir le mettre en
pls pour finir à les montres leroy en b
4 allez allez jolly jumper la chevauchée
roi b4 un adversaire te donne des coups
pour monter à aller roi prend b3
encaisse le pion peut-être un petit tour
17 là on prend lé faut prendre b6 prend
des 6 et ça va faire nu probablement
cette histoire
finale deux tours jamais évident à jouer
mais là c'est pas mal tombé 6 3 c3 ses
seins qui envoyait le pion à 4 et puis
on sacrifiera la tour contre le pion
c'est ça en fait à quatre à trois oncles
accra la tour contre le pion et on fera
nu comme ça tranquillement alors là est
ce qu'on peut faire ton prend ses six
prises à trois rois des 6 à 2 ces six as
et 7 ans la faut mettre leurs hommes
décèdent probablement oui mais de toute
façon ça fait nul puis on s'est alors
avec le rouen b cette soirée fait nul
mais là on peut y est maître la
d'amendés 6 3 c'est 8,3 b4 roi bessette
on va pouvoir faire d'amd de roye b 1re
ab4 machin et gagner je pense que cette
finale la gagne pour les noirs je peux
vous montrer comment
bon je vais un petit peu mais des en
laissant le roi blanc venir ici donc ça
on va la voir sa position va faire ça il
va devoir jouer ça on va jouer ça il va
jouer sa non on va pas jouer ça on va
jouer ici
il va jouer là si on réussit à faire ça
ça va gagner avec dame mat au prochain
et donc quand on fait dams est et ce qui
peut tenter roi la main qui ont fait
échec ça on se met là il vient là et on
n'arrive pas à finir le coup et on
n'arrive pas à finir le coup alors ils
ont fait nul mais est ce que ça pouvait
gagner ça bon alors c'est le nul 1-1 qui
a gagné mais ce que est ce qu'on pouvait
la gagne mais ça l'a ou pas donc çà çà
çà çà on pouvait la voir
cette position on pouvait la voir mais
après roy b71 mesdames 7 y avait aussi
roi 8 qui permettait de tenir que le
cadre est sûre roi ici ça est sûre ça ça
ça fait nul 1-1 sur la grosse question
est ce que tu peux gagner ces trucs là
ou pas mais apparemment c'était nul donc
beau tournoi j'espère que ça vous a plu
on se retrouve dimanche procheck
mercredi pro che slick jeudi le stream à
mardin title tuesday alors plein de
stream avenir plein de live donc
l'escrimé jeudi sur twitter les autres
sur youtube donc on sera partout
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne allez je mette la chaîne youtube
ou établi de stream sur eure sur youtube
si vous connaissez pas encore ce qui
m'étonnerait et je vous dis à très
bientôt
salut tout le monde ciao